[موسيقى]
اطلق في بيروت معرض خاص لدعم المصممين
والفنانين خلال فتره الاعياد يعود ريعه
بالكامل للفنانين والحرفيين المشاركين
بهدف تحفيزهم على الاستمرار في ظل الازمه
الاقتصاديه
الجميل
صناعتنا مميزه بالنوعيه وبالذوق بكل شيء
اكثر من ثلاثين فنانا متخصصا في الموسيقى
والرسم بالمزيك ورسم الجداريات يشاركون في
المعرض
بشتغل على وول بايبر فكر دايما باللي
حواليه وبالانتير الي هيعبي واللي حياه
مثل يجيء يلبسه همم عنجد فكر عن جد مثل
كانه همم فاشن ديزاينر
حاده في لبنان لم تؤثر على شغف الفنانين
اسمه كريزي همم
كثير من المواطنين لدعم الفن اللبناني
نشجع ال- ال- الابداع اللبناني والفنانين
اللبنانيه
حتى
نقدر نحسن الوضع لانه الوضع عن جد ماساوي
اذا بدك قوه الناس انظروا ماذا يمكن ان
يفعل لبنان هو شعار المعارض الذي يهدف الى
دعم الفن اللبناني